you feel press or
something don't record right it's like
go it's that
Wikipedia wor they even took it down
cu the brother told me so I speak
you he was saying no
no excuse
me is I don't know who he
is years
what how do you know that was the Holy
Spirit
are you a Catholic Born
Again born again okay so now the Holy
Spirit cannot be testified because why I
mean cannot be testif you know why
because I can bring you Catholic now and
he will tell you has holy spirits and
both you claim to have Holy Spirit but
both you believe different things so
which Holy Spirit speaking the truth the
the Protestants born again or the
Catholic or Holy Spirit I mean for me
for the Bible the Bible says that there
many leie Bel in at the end days no no
about the Bible you said you have Holy
Spirit correct and the Holy Spirit is so
you said the Holy Spirit you knew that
it was the Holy Spirit I can't bring you
Catholic now because all of us here we
cannot test the holy spirit that you
have we cannot that's the beauty of
Islam the beauty of Islam what Islam is
the truth not because I have Prophet
Muhammad inside me or abak inside me no
because the Quran is clear theah is
clear it goes in line with our sound
reasoning so my point here is you claim
to have Holy Spirit which we cannot see
I can bring you a Christian now who is a
Catholic he claims to have Holy Spirit
who cannot see and above you claim to
have Holy Spirit and above you don't
agree with each other I mean which holy
spirit so how can we know which holy
spirit is right I mean the Holy Spirit
doesn't tell you everything it leads you
into life but doesn't and it teaches you
the thing that Jesus teach he doesn't
tell you everything as human beings we
tend to have
disagreements you tend to have
disagreement same Christian you missing
the point miss the point here is not a
Shia and a sunnis and and sufis none of
us we claim to have Holy Spirit we can
know who with the truth by going back to
the Quran and the Sunnah so even
non-muslims can read what in theah but
when you come to because I ask you what
the reason you left Islam you you had a
Jin to be honest and I'm not sure if you
still have it or
not no but you said so now you claim
it's the Holy Spirit but my point here
here is which is a simple logical
rational point you claim to have Holy
Spirit correct I can bring a Catholic he
will tell you the same thing the Holy
Spirit led me to catholism so the holy
spirit is deceiving you or him which one
is been deceived by the Holy Spirit the
Holy Spirit was not
C okay explain I'll explain it to you
exp explain to you okay so Jesus Christ
says um just come and follow me he
doesn't he doesn't go on by Doctrine or
anything like that so with he with he
Catholic I believe the demon can possess
as an angel of Light so with he Catholic
I believe they do have demons they're
going to say same too we have demons to
I know this is why I told I told a
brother experiences do not Define
anything objetive so therefore you have
not left Isam based
upon therefore you hav not left Islam
based upon a rological
intellectual argument you left it based
upon
experience Jes yeah yeah and Jesus said
in Matthew 24:24 there will be many
false prophets even they would do
wonders they would do Miracles I agre
with so if you got a miracle from the
holy spirit that prove is the holy
spirit be a liar so therefore you cannot
tell us objectively why you left Islam
alhamdulillah I know this is not the
main reason though this this is
something what the main reason something
that me into it give me the main reason
this something this something L me into
right so then I always think okay like
what is Christianity or Islam TR and
this is what I stud this is what I study
relig I'm still learning I'm still
learning this why I came here and like
so you believe Jesus God I believe he's
okay say saying so so you believe God I
saying right step by step so is it
rational for you that God Almighty the
greatest who is inside woman private
party I mean if if Allah can come down
as a book right Allah never down as a
book if the is uncreated right why can't
I believe that God came down first okay
firstly what you just did is like
someone telling you you're rapist
instead of Defending yourself you said
but you're rapist too it's a fallacy
yeah it's a fallacy argument instead of
Defending yourself firstly a book is not
like God going inside one private party
that is disgusting to be God pretending
to be a baby that irrational firstly the
book that we have when we say the Quran
is the word of Allah and created mean
the attribute not the paper not the ink
not the the pen because the
book no
no who who's
father who the who the mother who the
mother father who's the mother of Eve
Eve she she was um she was she was made
she made from a man who's her mother
who's her mother mother mother
miraculous likewise she's miraculous has
no
father likewise Jesus is miraculous he
has no father yeah exactly but the
reason the reason why he was B right is
because he died but he died and came
back alive who can do that what came
back to life by himself by the way he
did no the in the Bible I'll show you he
said the father brought him to back to
life okay okay let's go to him yeah here
here the father brought him back to life
okay yes this
is this is why trity no no wait wait
wait which one put back to life the
father himself both them they both work
together this one
trity wait wait wait wait step by step
we're going to get it step by step
because that's the beauty of Islam how
with our rationality we can refute
Christianity okay so you said both them
yes they so they came together to give a
life they work together you don't have
they work together they don't work
together it's like a body the soul the
mind they don't work together together
okay so work together yes Jesus says I
cannot do anything but father does
likewise the father cannot do anything
the sun go show me what show me in the
Bible when the father said I can do
nothing by myself no I want to show
we're going the before that before that
no that's the most important the other
one this is the most important show let
us create no no no no show me because in
the Bible Jesus clearly said I can't do
nothing by myself he just said the
father said the same thing show us in
the Bible when the father said clearly I
can't do nothing by myself okay here it
is who
Passage
because in the New Testament in John 5:
19 Jesus gave them this answer very
truly I tell you the son can do nothing
by himself he can only do what he sees
his father doing because whatever the
father does son does also no no show me
where the father I can do nothing by
myself no no no no no no no no no
because what is in the Bible in the New
Testament Jesus always is the slave and
the servant of the father not the father
the father never asked her from Jesus
why is in the Bible Jesus cries for and
asking help from who from himself or
from the father from the father doesn't
make any sense before tell me
why let's go to before before this most
important more important you're Miss
you're ski you're going skipping that
top first more important you know more
important why it's not logical it's not
rational wait wait doesn't make any
sense your spirit blinded doesn't make
if me to finish listen he's not a church
I know it's stand but it's not church I
yeah yeah know you're preaching because
blinded blinded you okay no I'm I'm I'm
showing a logical rational argument why
Jesus being called doesn't make any
sense because if Jesus was called how on
the earth God Almighty the greatest was
crying for help the why okay now let's
get to that are you going to justify it
I'm explain why you going justify it so
except God was crying for
help what do you mean human nature so
here it is this is this is where
come
right this is why so he said in your
relationship with one another have the
same mindset as Christ Jesus who being
in the very no that's not Jesus that's
Paul
but first firstly first firstly what you
just said Jesus Jesus is the word of God
are word
God the word given to Paul is word of
God of God both is Son of God of God
expression of the father and God himself
Son of God John 1 vers one you'll get it
is he God or Son of God he's both so he
son of himself the son means title a
title is he son of himself or Son of God
the title brother I'm asking you I know
he's a title but is he Son of God or the
father of
God he is God because if J is God and
he's a father he's a father of himself
Jesus not a father J second member of
the Trinity okay so Jesus is see let so
he says in your relationship with one
another have the same mindset as Christ
Jesus who being in very nature God did
not consider equality with God something
to be used to his own Advantage rather
he made himself Nothing by taking the
very nature of a servant he made his
human likeness so we can see here Jesus
Christ was God he was in the form of God
and he not equal he was not equal to he
did not consider it he did not grasp it
who you grasp he did not Gras how come
he never grasp he's God no he he did not
he did not consider equality with God
that doesn't make any sense for
muslimas that he's not for Allah not for
Muslim it doesn't make sense you know
there's hope in he us
to
there Muslim nothing makes
sense expain explain be
honest shut you have to be honest what
you saying I know going to go
out I know for a fact when you go
outside the park you're going to watch
the video you think what the heck I was
talking about how on the earth you
standing here telling me that God
couldn't grasp that he was God he did
not consider it he did not consider it
what does it mean consider it but when
it says grasp other words when it says
grasp it's talking about the
comprehension like so he he could
comprehend as being we not grasp it that
God can do this God can come down so
Jesus he couldn't grasp that he no no I
meant to as human being say no no he
doesn't talk about he talk about Jesus
God he couldn't he couldn't C under it
he couldn't grasp it so God couldn't
grasp it that he was he became human
being of course because those are become
human God understand everything and he
knows everything subal when you compare
to Christianity got it so this is the
English version right go read
this when you compare the god of
Christianity compare Allah and watch
Allah perfect should which go in line
with any human being sound reasoning
brother here so here it says right when
when I talk the say here so who who
though who was in the form of God did
not count equality with God things be
say again not count equality with things
from the beginning from the beginning so
H was in the form of God not even though
H H was in the form of God did not count
equality for the god a thing to be gr so
that meaning wait he was in a form of
God but he couldn't that he was what no
he did not a thing to be GR in the terms
of it like um as humans we we should not
comprehend that God can do this so Jesus
Christ he did not consider it a hard
thing that a God can come down in the
form of human being to show to show how
to live life no no no doesn't say that
no it does read read the passage go the
passage don't read it that's not the
passage go back to the passage the Bible
go back the Bible he never CA himself
equal to God you know human being with a
sound doesn't mean doesn't mean doesn't
mean it doesn't go against divine nature
no no no it it goes It goes he didn't
consider it okay when when Jesus was a
baby was he God as well yes that yes he
was in his so that baby okay that baby
was God and human at same
time I mean you can say so yes no no
what do you believe foret about what I
can say I believe this why I do
this this this is my honest opinion
right hon opinion go on I believe Jesus
Christ manifested himself right so God
the second the second so it's something
called hyp Static Union and this is
where God created their body in which
the second the second member of the
Trinity took on and it's a manifestation
it's not like it's not like it's no
manifestation it's theame because end
with the word and the Word was with God
and the word is God and the word became
became flesh became here says became my
point here is so I'm going to ask you
question again so that baby that Mary
was holding that naked baby okay she was
changing his nappy and breastfeeding him
that was God yes take care of you help
you so Brother come on why you running
because you know well how you believe
was there why
Allah Allah in the
bur how can you believe
that how can you believe how can you
believe God the Christians out there I
know some of you there inallah you're
going to listen to this how on the earth
you just heard what this Christian
preacher saying and he left Islam I mean
like you you I'm not surprised why he
left Islam to be honest how on the earth
you believe a baby a baby that Mary was
changing his Napp and breastfeeding him
that was God Almighty the creat the
greatest Allah is far away from any
imperfection the fact that he was in
need of his mother take care of him
that's not God nature because God takes
care of everything no one takes care of
God that's right no one takes care of
God come on I know that already I know
that come on human is God In the Flesh
that's simple make any sense for
yourself but that's the revelation of
the script make any sense does anyone
take care of God does anyone take care
of
God ask him a question ask him a
question does anyone take care of God of
course no okay no step by step so no one
takes care of God so Mary when she was
taking care of Jesus who's that God the
S of man so that was not God was God in
theh yeah so that was God she was taking
care of
theim step by step to understand to
grasp because me what I like step by
step peeling down to make it simple for
everyone to understand so you just told
me which I agree with you no one takes
care of God God takes care of everyone
so the point here is when Mary was
taking care of Jesus looking after him
who's that God or not the the promise
Messiah no I'm Messiah scripture say
that brother answer me yes or no is that
good or
not that was the Messiah promised is a
messiah I agree I agree but who's that
God who's that God the Messiah is the
son of understand so he's not God the
Son of God that was not God Son of God
so he Son of God who's not God God is
the Son of God God that God or not God
he's the son of God I'm asking you don't
ask me question I'm asking you when when
Mary was taking care of Jesus
breastfeeding him was that God yes or no
the son of God I'm ask if you son was he
God or not he was the son of God he was
God he wasn't God the Son of God why you
understand Son of God Son of God and God
is playing around of course no that's
that's the revelation we got my brother
I'm ask you my brother what's your
name where you from origin from Peru you
Peru I'm from Buu ohu
yeah
[Music]
to
St no no no not controlling the question
I'm asking you st before you answer let
me repeat the question you like you or
not like that Jesus that God or not I
asked answered already Jesus is the son
of living God so he's not
God is the son of living God God
Divine he's not God God has only one s
of course he God he's
God Mary was taking care of God and he
just tell me no he just told me no one
take care of God then he tell me yes
Mary she was taking taking care of Jesus
and Jesus was God so therefore he just
refuted himself that's why all
Christians out there come to Islam
alhamdulillah many Christians are
accepted Islam Christianity doesn't make
any sense they are struggling to explain
the non-explanation thing how are you
going to explain to me standing here
justifying that God Almighty the one who
needs the one everyone's in need of him
he was crying brother before you need to
repent you need to check your brain
first because if you believe about Jesus
have respect Earth you believe that
someone was taking care of God may Allah
help you I ask Allah to
guide you I love Jesus Jesus the Savior
you s I love Jesus going save
himself he die and pay the F that you
deserve wait wait from all you going
save you yeah why he couldn't save
himself how he's going to save you
because he volunt pay he's going to ask
him my question what he
is if you cannot save yourself how you
going Tove he paid the fine for all sin
who repented why rep why we repented did
he save himself or not he G his life
because what in Hebrew 5 got the Bible
got the Bible get the Bible Hebrew 57
Hebrew read it read it Hebrews 57 he
said on the last day in his flesh he was
praying to who he was praying to God to
save him know he would save himself so
therefore Jesus never came to give up
himself he was asking God to help him
come to Islam Islam is simple only let
me say about Islam according to the
Hebrew who the father of Jesus who the
father of Jesus father so saying the
true God is yeah the say the saying so
why you qu if you don't see believe the
saying scripture he quotes because Jesus
addresses father look at him not me okay
father has only one son and that is
Jesus what do you know about Islam Islam
I don't know there is no single Islam
Islam Jesus was a Muslim yeah do you
know why Muslim mean someone
let me finish Muslim is Arabic
terminology no Divine no Divine
terminology but you have finish to
understand yeah you you speak
now only speak you want to speak go
speak say Islam is a
human but you don't know about Islam how
do you know human Islam is a term is a
word is not div not in the Holy Quran
the nothing say show me
the was Islam exactly that exactly Islam
Allah
Allah where in the Bible in the Bible
yeah so where you say oh in the Quran
it's in the Quran Quran how can I be
true it's about time anyway let
me are you chrisan are you Christian
years are you Christian are you
Christian you Christian correct show me
show me in the Bible where Jesus said
he's a Christian Jesus is the found of
the Christianity no no show me where he
said he was a Christian no Jesus so he
was not Christian show me what Jesus
said he's the found of
Christianity show me in the Bible where
Jesus said he's the found of
Christianity he find the way and the
true and the LI I never said that no no
no no no show me where Jesus said I'm
the
is from Romania he said he
[Applause]
from South America yeah
ald every Friday we give da at least one
person becomes a Muslim alhamdulillah
why because Islam goes in line with the
sound resoning with the natural
inclination Christianity doesn't how on
Earth you standing here in the park
trying to justify God who is perfect who
was in need of help
aldah for Islam and we have to be what
they call it very grateful to